bonjour monsieur rigoler rose merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors josep borrell or en quarts à il a
été fou ans sur ce qui allait se passer
pendant ces deux jours je le cite nous
allons discuter des problèmes et des
propositions de solutions aux questions
quel problème est quelle question
oui il a dit qu'il a niées d'ailleurs
consacré son déplacement à tous les
aspects problématiques donc sans être
plus explicite
ça fait référence évidemment aux
tensions de ces derniers jours de ces
dernières semaines particulièrement
entre la france et la turquie
et ça embarrasse évidemment tous les
toutous les européens parce que c'est
une relation difficile la turquie est un
partenaire difficile à la fois au sein
de l'otan et par rapport à l'union
européenne puisque évidemment il ya
toujours là
la question de l'adhésion potentiel de
la turquie à l'union européenne qui a
été repoussée met donc en arrière-plan
évidemment c'est une relation très
complexe avec entre paris et ankara
évidemment en ce moment mais plus
largement entre bruxelles et ankara
surtout quand en arrière plan il ya la
question des réfugiés qui était d'une
actualité brûlante avec la syrie et qui
potentiellement peut le redevenir avec
la libye on va à une relation assez
répandue entre les 27 avec la france une
relation compliquée donc avec la turquie
puis il ya aussi la poursuite des
forages turcs 1 dans la zone économique
maritime de la chypre ya jean yves le
drian qui a laissé entendre que de
nouvelles sanctions pourraient être
envisagées sur ce dossier par la france
quel genre de sanctions que ce qu on le
sert la marge de manoeuvre de la turquie
c'est bien évidemment les réfugiés vous
l'avais dit à l'instant oui alors il
faut rappeler que les sanctions ont déjà
pris des sanctions déjà été adopté en
octobre 2019 par le mur paix par le
conseil européen et le ministre le drian
ce fait référence et une réunion
prochaine le 13 juillet 2020 pour
justement des ministres des affaires
étrangères de l'union européenne pour
envisager des sanctions supplémentaires
il ya effectivement la question des
forages en méditerranée orientale et et
la difficulté de des relations entre
bruxelles
en tout cas l'union européenne et la
turquie sur cette affaire puisque
l'union européenne évidemment a défendu
le point de vue de la grèce et de chypre
en l' occurrence et ça suscite
évidemment des tensions accrues avec
ankara qui il faut le rappeler considère
que ces intérêts ne sont pas pris en
compte
ankara qui n'est pas signataire de la
convention droit de la mer et donc sur
les délimitations des oeufs de la
dizaine zone exclusive économique
exclusive et ce qui alimente justement
la complexité du dossier
alors pour parler de ce pont tension
tout est entre paris et ankara
concrètement séparés qui accuse la
turquie de violer l'embargo sur les
armes en libye
oui là ça envoie à l'incident du du 10
juin dernier et lorsqu'il ya eu
effectivement à propos d'un cargo qui
était à destination de de la libye une
tentative d'identification qui s'est
manifestement il ya tous les éléments du
dossier sont pas éclaircis puisque le
rapport de l'otan des cas s'est classé
confidentiel défense
mais ça permet justement la turquie de
dire que la version française n'est pas
étayée et les français considèrent que
les autres membres de l'otan à quelques
exceptions près n'ont pas n'ont pas pris
la mesure du problème qui était posée
par par le jeu supposé de la turquie en
la circonstance
donc ça évidemment ça embarrasse tout le
monde et notamment dans le processus de
négociations qui devraient pouvoir avoir
lieu pour la syrie qui avait été initiée
notamment avec la conférence de berlin
en janvier dernier et qui pour l'instant
est un poids mort d'autant plus en point
mort que sur le terrain chacun des camps
prend prendre position pour marquer des
lignes rouges
et encore dernièrement la une base
reprises aux forces du marché l'after la
base al attiyah a été bombardé par des
avions à commune donc sur le terrain la
tension est à son comble emmanuel
apprend par la même responsabilité
historique est criminel en évoquant la
turquie des mots très forts
oui c'est des mots qu'il a prononcés
lors d'une visite en allemagne aux côtés
d'angela merkel
la position allemande d'ailleurs est
beaucoup plus prudente que la position
française
elle s'inscrit dans justement
l'organisation de la conférence de
berlin mais ça a permis au président de
macron fectivement de d'insister sûr ce
point la réponse du berger à la bergère
puisque mevlut cavusoglu a considéré que
dans le cas dans le cas de la france il
y avait une approche destructrice par
rapport à à la question libyenne
donc en réalité c'est un échange on va
dire de de rhétorique pour l'instant
mais qui est susceptible potentiellement
de dégénérer et c'est ce qui inquiète
justement tous les partenaires des deux
des uns et des autres justement comment
ça pourrait dégénérer cette crise entre
paris et ankara et passer assez près
d'un incident grave dans le cadre dudit
du contrôle du bateau au large de la
libye le 10 juin dernier
et c'est précisément pour éviter ce type
de problème que joseph bourrel a décidé
de se déplacer en car pour essayer de
trouver des solutions à une situation
qui pour l'instant est tout sauf en voie
d'apaisement et là on sent un relatif
isolement des français par rapport à ses
partenaires
parce que plus le taux français monte et
plus l'embarras est perceptible à la
fois du côté de l'otan est partiellement
du côté de l'union européenne même si
les français peuvent s'appuyer sur des
alliés solides
il ya quand même un malaise qui est
perceptible parce que on sent bien que
la situation pourrait dégénérer et c'est
ce que personne ne souhaite
david rigoulet roze merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes chercheur spécialiste du
moyen-orient associé à l'iris merci
d'avoir été en direct